Nos dicen: "Un sociólogo que estudia fertilidad
en Argentina y Bolivia desea probar si existe
alguna diferencia en el número promedio de bebés
que tienen las mujeres en cada país. El sociólogo
obtuvo una muestra aleatoria de mujeres de
cada país. Aquí están los resultados de su
prueba". Podemos ver que tenemos una muestra de
75 mujeres en Argentina, ellas tienen una media
de 2.4 bebés cada una, una desviación estándar
de 1.5 y un error estándar de la media de 0.17.
También tenemos estos estadísticos similares
para Bolivia, y tenemos también la prueba t
para las medias diferentes de donde obtuvimos
estos estadísticos. Después nos dicen: "Supón
que se han cumplido todas las condiciones para la
inferencia. Al nivel de significancia de α = 0.05,
¿hay evidencia suficiente para concluir
que existe una diferencia en el número
promedio de bebés que tienen las mujeres en cada
país?" Pausa el video e intenta responder. Ok,
vamos a trabajar juntos. Aquí tenemos una prueba
de hipótesis clásica donde nuestra hipótesis nula
es que las medias son las mismas, es decir,
la media en Argentina es la misma que la media
en Bolivia, y nuestra hipótesis alternativa
es que las medias son diferentes. Entonces,
si suponemos nuestra hipótesis nula, preguntémonos
cuál es la probabilidad de obtener esta diferencia
entre las medias. Eso es lo que establece nuestro
valor P, es decir, que tenemos una probabilidad
de 0.31 o 31% de probabilidad de obtener esta
diferencia entre las medias. Ahora, suponiendo
la hipótesis nula, si tenemos una probabilidad
por debajo de nuestro nivel de significancia,
es decir, α, entonces debemos establecer que
esta es una probabilidad muy baja, por lo tanto
podemos rechazar la hipótesis nula y sugerir la
hipótesis alternativa. Pero en esta situación,
si comparamos P con α, podemos ver que nuestro
valor P es claramente mayor que nuestra α,
es decir 0.31 sin lugar a duda es mayor
que 0.05, así que en este caso no podemos
rechazar la hipótesis nula y, por lo tanto,
no hay evidencia suficiente para concluir
que existe una diferencia en el número promedio
de bebés que tienen las mujeres en cada país.